in this problem a given aerobic digestor
has a 50t diameter and a height of 8T it
is capable of treating 8,000 gallons per
day of thickened secondary sludge and
has a volatile solids loading rate of
about
0.04 pounds per cubic feet day if 60% of
the matter in the digestor is volatile
what is the solid's concentration of the
sludge in the digestor expressed as a
percent so the first thing we need to do
is use our reference manual the problem
is asking us to find the solids
concentration if we search solids
concentration this will bring us to
chapter 6 section
6.8.0 to a section below activated
Sledge treatment called solids loading
system and this will be on page
455 so looking at that equation we can
write it down as
follows so f SL equal
[Music]
8.34
Q
X where SL is the solid's loading rate
in pounds per day Q is the volumetric
flow rate in million gallons per day and
X is the suspended solids concentration
in milligrams per
liter so let's start looking into our
problem to see what things we can fill
in we have flow but it needs to be
converted into the proper units
first so Q equal
8,000 gallons per
day converted so that one
mgal over 10 6
gal and this is going to give us
0.008
mgal per day
we've also been given the volatile
solids loading rate in units of pounds
per cubic feet Day note that the
reference manual wants this in pounds
per day so if we write this
out we can see what terms are still
missing and guess how to solve for
[Music]
them
the reference manual also contains the
units for the 8.34 conversion number
here and that's going to be pounds over
mgal all over milligrams per
liter now Q we just solved for and
that's going to be
0.008 mgal per
day and then finally X is going to be
millgram per
liter and also we can include the 60%
number here now as a decimal to account
only for those matter that are
volatile so if we start Crossing
out units we can see what's
missing so the only thing left to solve
for is going to be cubic feet how can we
do that well we've been given the
dimensions of the digester so if we want
to get the solids loading rate here into
pounds per day as is requested by the
problem in or by the reference
manual we can
simply use the volume of the tank to
find the loading rate in only pounds per
day so let's do
that
[Music]
so note that we need to realize that the
digestor is going to be a cylinder so we
can calculate the volume of the tank and
then find the loading rate in pounds per
day so the equation of a cylinder is
going to be Pi D ^2 over 4 * H which for
us is going to be
Pi 50 ft
squared over
4 * 5
ft and the volume here is going to be
9812 cubic
feet updating the equation here
therefore we can
see
0.04 pound per cubic foot Day times
9812 cubic
fet is going to give
us
[Music]
39248 pounds per
day so if we update our equation one
more time we can get 3
92.4 pounds per day equals
8.34 lb over mgal
over Mig per
liter time
0.008 M gal per
day times x in milligrams per liter time
0.6 so once complete all of our terms
are ready to be crossed out so we can
solve for
x so X here is going going to be about
[Music]
98416 mg per
liter finally we need to know how to
convert x given in milligrams per liter
into a percent as that is what the
problem is asking
for so we can use a rule of
thumb we can use the rule of thumb to
see that every 1% of solid's
concentration is equivalent to about
10,000 mg per liter I'll expand on this
in a
second for
now we can set it up like
this and since we have close to 10,000
mg per liter we can see that our answer
is about
1%
so I'm sure you are
wondering why where does this come
from so what's the supporting math
behind this rule of thumb let's go
through
it so we can start by saying 1% solids
concentration is the equivalent
of 1
kg of
solids per every 100
water a unit conversion here we could
say it is equivalent
to there are 1 million mg of
solids in one
kilogram of
solids next we would have to know
that 1 kgr of
water is the
weight of one
liter of
water simplifying this
out we can
get one
million
milligrams over 100
L otherwise known
as 10,000 milligram per liter so that is
where this rule of thumb comes from and
you can find it in other references to
Wastewater
engineering so to solve this problem
let's review you need to know the
following things the first thing is
going to be you need to know the correct
equation to use which comes from the
reference manual next you need to
recognize that you're only concerned
with the volatile matter so even though
the equation itself doesn't give a spot
for the percentage of volatile
matter this 60% will still play a role
three you need to know that the tank is
a cylinder when you're solving for the
volume so that you can get your loading
rate into the correct
units and four possibly the most
important part here is you simply have
to know what this rule of thumb is to
make your conversion from percents to
milligrams per liter or reverse
depending on what the problem might ask
of you so there's a number of steps here
and some of them do kind of require
backgrounds knowledge of some aspects of
Wastewater
engineering however if you can keep
things like this in mind this rule of
thumb because I don't think it's in the
reference manual the remaining steps in
the problem you should be able to figure
out I guess also knowing to apply the
60% number here so yeah this is probably
one of the more difficult problems I
think you would see on the exam but if
you can keep these steps broken down one
at a
time you'll be able to solve
it